do you snuck a lot well i am a snack
you're a snack and we're gonna swap the
snacks
okay
[Music]
i'm q i'm american i'm hitomi i'm
japanese-american
hi i'm ria i'm japanese hi i'm alex i'm
american
and today we're going to be swapping
some snacks yeah see which ones
are better i don't think i've ever tried
a japanese snack before
in my life oh what
these are classics yeah i mean they're
pretty much
the same shape style
maybe not flavor which we'll try out but
they're chips in a can i can't believe
you have a tube snack too
yeah but it's shorter look yeah portion
control yeah what is this
these are pizza flavor this is like as
american as you can get
and the flavor it's lemon
whoa this is really cute this is like
get ready to roll
[Laughter]
all right cheers
hmm these are great it tastes like
artificial pizza
the pizza's the best because it's like
it really does taste like pizza
this is lighter like the texture is a
little bit crispier
this has a lot more like density to it i
like mine
i like mine
[Music]
this is like a six dollar movie snack
yeah but they're good though like and i
promise you the only thing i've ever
eaten was adam
my sweet snack it's mochi mochi
chocolate
it's mochi but have you had a roasted
tea
yeah actually okay because it's roasted
it has more depth
you know that sounds magical these are
just like
it's no depth it's just like you eat it
you're just there
how cute is that though it comes with a
little like pork
okay so what we know for sure japanese
snacks
are not accessible or not very
accessible but it's like when you open
them you gotta open them again
oh so cute do i eat the whole thing yeah
maybe i'm gonna buy it
it's really good yeah i like it the
texture is a 100
like yeah this is a very light chocolate
and like the tea flavor comes
through and so i i really enjoy it mochi
has like this this is good though
i'm gonna try who parts
i love whoppers because
i don't know i guess because it's a
mulch it's a fun thing it might
happen in my mouth my mouth but no like
whoppers
i like it but let me tell you
what i like i'm a dark chocolate person
[Music]
baby crabs so these are literally just
itty bitty tiny crabs as you could see
i have a hard time eating things that
look like they do when they're alive
i've been like clawed by a crack what is
it
pinched and pinched by a crab it's okay
it's that it's dead
it's like a rational fear like i don't
know i might come alive in my mouth or
something well these
are flaming hot cheetos these are a
classic
here and it comes in this little dish
another dish
yeah good luck everything i try to open
is so i feel like i'm gonna open these
and they're just gonna pop in my face
don't think it's crabber don't think
it's fish i like seafood oh
this is her oh
i got a leg
i can't i can't eat anymore oh yeah
thank you what are you doing to me
they're a lot crunchier than i ever
imagined oh yeah
thank goodness have a cheeto
yes yes this is a good snack like it's
looking at me like
i can't oh wow spider it's spicy right
it's spicy
and i love hot cheetos
just a perfect teenager snack
yeah cheetos are great they're like nice
crunchy
the flamin hot are spicy a lot of flavor
i think i like it better i do tuna for
sure
so i have for you jalapeno flavored
potato chips
everybody loves a potato chip it's easy
it's delicious
these are squid chips but it's actually
more like tempura
chips a chip fried squid it's just a
drawing
there's a little drawing of a squid on
the back
what have you done again really think
about squid squid it's just a drawing
you see how excited i am to try these
like the last ones just because they
look like crab
way off like if they were like this
it smell like jalapeno yeah cause
they're jalapeno flavored
lizard fish paste oh my god i just
never read the ingredients i mean i like
calamari
so uh-huh
hmm these smell a little lemony
these are not spicy is there fishy no
yeah it's lemony you these are so good
no heat though like there's no spiciness
there's not very much heat
these taste like a sweet and spicy type
of dill
i'm all for it i'll give you this one
good
wow i wonder what this is
they're crab flavored crackers
everything is crab everything is like a
fish beautiful so like a corn chip
oh we have another one like a corn chip
and they have like the coolest shape
you put them on their finger yeah like a
little hat
i haven't had these in so long
yo while i struggle with like three
got two
[Music]
one two
whoa it doesn't taste like crab
trust me
do you see the crab leg in there i'm
just kidding yeah
yeah you know it's not bad but i choose
the bugles
maybe more flavor right yeah it has a
crunch
but it's almost it's like if
styrofoam could be a chip
this is it finger hat actual hat
[Music]
bonus round this is a
very nostalgic treat um it is
called botan rice candy it's something
you would find
in the grocery store like in the aisle
when you're checking out and you have
like gum
and you know your candy bars and stuff
this is most likely going to be there
i present you a little little present
i feel like this is going to be way
easier to open oh my gosh
it's always another layer oh but these
guys
okay you could actually eat the wrapper
if you like open it this wrap yeah so i
don't even have to
take this out nope that's part of it
okay
did you buy it i do oh
these are good right so this is a bonus
nut
oh both is snack it's sushi
but it's candy and we're gonna make it
together it's so cute
yeah right oh my gosh it comes with a
dropper
put water just like until this line
this is rice rice and
like actually oh wow it's called the
rock
is it doing it yeah look it's like
individual oh my gosh
it should be a seaweed
and this is rice so we're gonna shape it
okay
look you wanna do that
look at that tuna oh
slid right out look how cute those are
the little fishing this is the best kind
of snack
[Music]
i thought that these snacks were on both
sides they're really great
um they were all fun which is like a
that's a plus one like the kids
the kids want to have fun and so do it's
great i knew you guys had
great snacks i think you picked some
that weren't my favorite but
also i definitely feel like your snacks
are like way more sophisticated you
can't go wrong with snacks it's
it's like it could be any part of the
meal
pre-post so
yeah yeah and it could be savory or
sweet
so or it could be crab
[Music]
you